this is a passion real passion of yours
this project yeah and it to explain it
easily I think a lot of people are
familiar with Anthony Bourdain show yes
he travels around all over the world and
he eats this exotic food and they it has
these adventures is your show it's it's
sort of like a comedic version of that
would you say no I would say that I'm
exactly like Anthony Bourdain if he was
afraid of everything oh here oh okay
this is you instead of so you don't want
to eat the octopus I the way that
Anthony Bourdain done oh and I'm not
going to Beirut to get shot at I'm not
eating that part of the animal that
makes us all girly like this okay I'm
like the nice Jewish boy version right
right
so you're passionate about food did you
grow up eating well as a child I can't
say that I can was your mom a great cook
well why put this on me I wanna I was
talking about your mom I know my mother
was a very good cook of Irish food my
mom was a very good cook of German
immigrant food yeah really it was your
mom a good cook
she's great my mom I just want to say
that my mom is fantastic and what kind
of cook eautiful she once made for
Passover this is my people now I'm
talking about I got confused okay she
once made matzah lasagna Oh
instead of sheets of pasta sheets of
matzah yeah it was like a cardboard
souffle right right so it was not that
she let's just say maybe cooking wasn't
her forte let's say that okay all right
but grated many many other things yes
but not food uh does your mom mind you
talking about her that way when you're
on television she has a great sense of
humor
and I'm sure you're a very nice son in
many other ways I am you know if you
watch the show there in the show yes
we're in the show and they they steal
the thing there there fantastic right if
their parents on eras of Everybody Loves
Raymond is really based on your parents
mostly based on them a little bit of
raise parents - yes yeah yeah okay you
went to Italy you go to Harris yes Spain
yeah had all these kinds of foods you
went to Hong Kong
you ate what's called a 100 year old egg
yes it's not really a hundred years old
it just tastes that way let's take a
look I think we have well look at the
segment first and then we'll talk about
it okay go to you it's okay you have to
relive it okay ladies first and or any
do you put any sauce or anything else no
I just you know like that and and white
is yeah I got a minute the whole thing
yeah see Yolo
[Music]
it just has like a weird all that
yesterday that's the right after that
the lady to my left she said maybe we
should google it yeah I say now we
google it after well what is it then
it's not a hundred years old but no hey
that looks nasty it's preserved in lime
and ash and it's buried underground
until it takes on that green yolk and
brown white so it rots you ate a rotten
egg the first thing you taste is very
very very rotten egg
this is then supplanted by an
overpowering wave of ammonia what wine
pairs well yeah I started to call this
cat pee yeah oh my god sounds awful it
is yeah yeah well not everything can be
great but I'm not out to find the
grossest thing I'm actually out to get
you to travel I want you to travel and I
want to show you the best stuff yes but
yes not everything we put in our mouths
is gonna be fantastic hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos please